students from Marjorie Stoneham Douglass
High School in Florida will resume
classes next Tuesday that's nearly two
weeks after the shooting that killed 17
people about 100 of them are making
preparations to confront lawmakers on
gun control before they return to school
that's right this afternoon they will go
to Florida's Capitol in Tallahassee to
say this must be the last massacre
tomorrow they will march in the first
organized rally of the never again
moment other students from California to
Washington DC are holding their own
protests calling on legislators to
reform gun laws Adriana Diaz is in
parkland Florida where survivors of last
week's shooting hope their voices will
be heard Adrianna good morning good
morning these students have quickly
become the new face of an old debate and
they say they'll be unrelenting in their
call for stricter gun laws we asked a 14
year old last night if she's nervous
about talking to state lawmakers at the
Capitol and she said I got this I pulled
this together in a matter of 48 hours it
is just absolutely overwhelming 17 year
old Jacqueline Koren is leading the
charge for change a hundred kids
standing in the State Capitol building
of Tallahassee is a very symbolic
message with less than 24 hours before
these teen activists hit the road to
meet with Florida legislators they're
making sure nothing is overlooked
it's literally like taking over our
lives but in a good way a week after
their school was shattered by gunfire
these high schoolers won their state to
impose stricter laws on people with the
history of mental illness and an
outright ban on assault weapons we need
to take a stance because since we have
the lime lakes place on us
this tragedy who he had to seize that
opportunity so we can ensure that
there's gonna be changed in the future a
new nationwide poll taken after the
shooting finds that America is still
divided on an assault weapons ban fifty
percent support a ban forty six percent
oppose and the students will likely face
an uphill battle in Florida a state with
some of the least restrictive gun laws
in the country the never again movement
has been picking up steam on social
media
since the Fort Lauderdale rally Saturday
protests were held across the country on
Monday and two nationwide marches are in
the pipeline for next month
Alex Wynne is one of the movements
founders now it stops never again will
this happen and never again will it
happen in this country or any other
country for that matter we are the
future we are the ones that are going to
make the change
you know if Congress or the state or
anyone doesn't want to do anything you
know what we're gonna do it before they
head to Tallahassee many of the students
will attend the funeral of 16 year old
Carmen central her parents said she was
going to change the world
maybe her classmates can change it for
her Nora
Adriana thank you so much